When solving this inequality, we can add one to both sides to isolate the 3x.
Next, to isolate x, we divide each part by 3. So, we know x is greater than
negative 3 but less than 7. But this isn't our answer. You want it to be an
interval notation. We know x is between these values. So, I have negative 3 and
7, and I have parentheses on the end, because we can't be equal to negative 7 or
negative 3. Here's the solution on a number line. We're almost done with Unit 2.
I hope so far, you've gained a stronger understanding of satisfying conditions
and learning when one condition or both conditions must be met. Let's wrap up
this entire section with one last lesson, a lesson with absolute value equations
and inequalities.